new york attorney general leticia
james's office is undertaking both a
civil and criminal probe against donald
trump her office has been investigating
the financial dealings of the trump
organization for nearly three years
claiming to have significant evidence of
alleged fraud stating the company used
fraudulent or misleading tactics in how
they reported their assets to get
economic benefits
the manhattan district attorney has also
been at work on a criminal investigation
into the trump organization's finances
since 2019
but after all this time there have been
no lawsuits and no charges filed against
trump
so what's the holdup
legal experts told forbes white-collar
investigations can take years to pursue
and when the target is a former
president prosecutors want to spend
their time and make sure they have
enough evidence
you put the trump name on it and it just
by default makes it a sexier case and
they're going to spare no investigative
resource
and there's a lot to investigate
prosecutors need to read through
thousands of pages of documents as well
as gather witness testimony to build
their case
james said her office's civil
investigation has been slowed by the
trump's delay tactics
it took nearly two years in court for
the former manhattan d.a to even get
access to trump's tax returns
then court documents allege the company
withheld some email records from james
for over a year blaming the delay on
email migrations she has repeatedly had
to get a judge to compel testimonial
documents from the trump family because
they won't cooperate voluntarily the
trumps are expected to fight the request
which could drag out the proceedings
further and potentially play out in
court as of now james's office hasn't
reached a final decision whether to
bring a lawsuit against trump or his
company and it remains to be seen how
much trouble trump could ultimately find
himself in as a result of the probes the
civil one requires a lower burden of
proof and can only result in a lawsuit
the criminal ones could result in
charges against trump his associates or
the company the trump family and trump
organization have harshly criticized
james's investigation and denied any
wrongdoing and accused the attorney
general of misleading the public with
her latest court filing
[Music]
you